I also remember that while we were you
know in the 14th century chilling with
Leonardo da Vinci and you know getting
rid of this Valley Girl accent as
Danielle I mean I don't even know if I
can do the voice anymore can you you
just drop your ass and speak in Royal
pronunciations we can your accent was so
good oh I don't know yours was great we
were all you know doing the best we
could I was living in London a little
bit easier
you're American Melanie's from New
Zealand and Megan's myself so I think we
all did really well yeah
really hard on them because we chose
like a royal pronunciation something
sort of very
um European neutral yeah um not
anachronistic appropriate for the times
but that we could all speak being from
completely different places but while we
were dressed like this and doing our
accents by day we were totally partying
by night I mean we are so much fun Megan
I know there was one party for you that
particularly stood out oh god oh no this
was a dinner party that Angelica had and
it you know she had a brilliant French
chef which was amazing we were also
excited to go I was with Oliver who was
my fiance at the time and
um we all got there you guys had made
some kind of a arrangement to have a
vegetarian option and I didn't know what
was coming down the pike and these
plates come out with a full entire Goose
liver with like pink and gelatinous and
huge and jiggling on the plate oh my
gosh and I'm sitting there where Ali and
I are looking at each other just saying
to just get through just get through
just eat this thing Angelica was like
delicious
Now We're Here honoring the 25th
anniversary of Ever After so if you're
just tuning in now you might be like
wait what is going on here
however I'm so happy to be living in
this world that changed my life forever
you know when you have those very clear
times in your life incidences situations
circumstances that you know your life
went in a better direction for and from
and this is that for me there's no
question I know it and we got to all do
it together
um do gray I just can't love you more
thank you so much for being literally
the prince everyone's Prince Prince
Henry
[Music]
foreign